de los Derechos Humanos Además le
preguntó esto por qué el presidente
Nicolás Maduro no fue digamos a hacer
presencia a este acto protocolar donde
sí la tiene el presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro Bueno aquí hay muchas
lecturas que se pueden dar y es
precisamente esta dificultad y este
costo que puede tener la foto política
de Gustavo Petro con Nicolás maduro y es
que en su discurso Petro sí ha sido
mucho más cuidadoso que venía de ti y se
refiere a la sociedad venezolana a los
venezolanos a los hermanos venezolanos a
Venezuela y evita toda Costa referirse a
Nicolás maduro y es que es muy costoso
hoy precisamente hoy 26 de septiembre
tomarse una foto al lado de una persona
que está siendo señalada haber cometido
crímenes de lesa humanidad Entonces el
escenario la frontera para para Gustavo
Petro tampoco es sencillo es una
victoria temprana Por supuesto porque es
una promesa una de sus principales
promesas de campaña pero acercarse mucho
a Nicolás Maduro a título personal eso
le podría co Star mucho en su imagen
internacional